Amanda Bynes reportedly hospitalized the
actress was placed on a psychiatric hold
after she was found roaming the streets
of Los Angeles naked according to TMZ
the incident happened Sunday morning
Amanda allegedly flagged a car down
telling the driver she was coming down
from a psychotic episode before calling
9-1-1 her cell she was then taken to a
nearby police station where a mental
health Team later determined she needed
to be admitted
ETS reached out to binds his rep for
comment
not long after the alleged incident
Amanda's on off again Beyonce Paul
Michael shared this cryptic post on
Instagram that's how I say I'm just out
no you'll ever have to hear from me
solo
I'm just gonna be out for a minute so
I love y'all Instagram peace Amanda's
conservatorship was terminated in March
of 2022 which she was first place under
in 2013 with her mother Lynn having
legal control over her but last year the
star provided facts that the
conservatorship is no longer needed
Amanda shared her thoughts on a chance
at a new beginning at the time in a
statement to E.T in the last several
years I have been working hard to
improve my health so that I can live and
work independently I will continue to
prioritize my well-being in this next
chapter over the weekend E.T caught up
with Amanda's former all that co-stars
Keenan Thompson and Kel Mitchell where
they sent their well wishes have you
been in touch with her do you know how
she's doing yeah I haven't sadly yeah
I've just been you know praying for her
you know and it's awesome to see she's
doing better which is great and we're
just continuing to pray for her and on
her journey seeing her it's answered
prayers that she's doing a lot better
yeah
[Music]
thank you